so i have to be honest with you season
one of upload was my
feel good
laugh out loud escape reality show of
last year watched it a few times so i
have been dying
to see season two what do you love about
this season you know because i can
imagine with the first season you're
getting used to the characters and the
story lines and the themes and then you
really i feel like you can have fun with
season two
uh you actually nailed it um i think
what greg does so well is he finds
he the casting process is really big for
him and he finds character or people
that really embody these characters and
throughout the first season he figures
out you know more and more about
you as a person and as the character and
in season two he really leads into that
and i think everybody was able to bring
more of themselves to it everybody was
more comfortable greg you know really i
think found what made the first season
so special and leaned into it in the
second season um
we were all closer you know we we shot
the pilot a year later we shot the first
season of the year later we shot the
second season so we you know i know and
now a year later it comes out so you
know we've
we all feel like although it was a
second season we feel like we've known
each other for a lot longer which which
is really sweet and and
you know we're all fans of each other
which i think is really really great i
love being able to be in a scene and
watch kevin or zainab or allegra and
andy like anyone and just have them make
me laugh and uh you know i'm i'm pretty
lucky i got a pretty good job yeah it's
it's such a great show because you fall
in love with all the characters everyone
has different personalities but
everyone's so funny like it's like the
quick lines it's so good um
so i can imagine with you like trying to
shoot those scenes um there's a scene in
the second season just to sorry to cut
you out there's a scene in the second
season it's it might be in the finale to
the second last or the last episode and
you can see me trying really hard not to
laugh it's kevin and i in his room
um and there's some really great music
playing and
um they used a take where i'm trying to
keep it together because it was just it
was just one of those things where it
made a lot of sense but kevin
i mean the whole cast kevin's my wife's
favorite luke is my wife's favorite
character including me so you know we um
i'm a big fan of his i'm a big fan of
the whole cast it's very fun to shoot
yeah i honestly can we can see it like
we can tell um
the idea of the show the whole concept
kind of freaked me out at first then i
was like oh this could be actually
really interesting i'm sure you've
questioned you know given the
opportunity if technology allowed in the
future would you ever be game for
uploading yourself to a digital
afterlife
yeah i mean um i kind of look at it like
this if it's if it's life or death
and uploads in the middle then i'll take
upload i'll spend more time with friends
and family and if i ever don't like it
i'll jump in the torrent and see what's
next that's true i like that all right
you've thought about this that's good um
so a big part of the reason why fans
obviously love this show too is
we love a good love triangle so i want
to know how messy the nora ingrid
and nathan love triangles going to be
this season
well i mean season one nathan and nora
are really coming together and it looks
like it's going to work out at the end
of the first season and then everything
that can go wrong goes wrong and
he
you know he freezes he runs out of data
in 2gig he's not able to say i love you
back
he doesn't know if she's okay he doesn't
know where she is and all of a sudden
ingrid who he had finally gotten away
from is there and she's uploaded and
she's essentially sacrificed herself to
be with him and
that's a big deal this is someone who he
you know has had a relationship with who
really he did really care about but not
only that he can't find nora from two
gigs so he kind of needs to
play the game for a minute and see if he
can find her and then
you kind of quickly find out that she
doesn't want to be found and that life
has moved forward and and nora has found
somebody else and nathan has to step
back and say okay
maybe i have to see if there really is
something there with with ingrid maybe
uploading changes her the same way it
changed him maybe she can grow as a
human being
maybe she can't
we will have to see
okay so obviously about giving too much
away on a scale of one to ten how
intense is is ingrid's love for nathan
this season and and wanting it to work
it it really comes to a
like a 11 or a 12. um it's uh
it's it's it's a problem for sure but uh
allegra is so funny and so sweet she
gets away with saying things that most
people wouldn't dream of
i know it's so funny and then did i read
that season three is already being
written
yeah um so greg i mean greg thought of
this show 30 years ago so he has a ton
of ideas um and he's been hard at work
on season three with the
hopes that season two does well and and
we get to jump back into production you
know we we all love making the show yeah
obviously it's taken a long time between
seasons most of that due to covid but
also it's a big show with a lot of
visual effects greg is just kind of
raring to go and chomping at the bit and
fingers crossed we premiere well i i
want this to happen
so much like i'll be devastated because
i love this show so much well i'm glad
you like it so much i love that your
wife loves it and it's so good
thank you um okay so what can you tease
us about
code eight because i know you guys shot
part two right
we did um
we're so lucky netflix you know the show
the movie uh premiered on netflix in
most parts of the world it was it was on
crave here or in canada and a couple
other territories but netflix for most
of the world and we were very lucky that
we did very well
and netflix came in for the sequel and
and bought the entire world so it is a
netflix original
they they gave us a ton of freedom uh
but really helped us out where we needed
it and uh it's bigger it's better um you
know myself and steven and jeff and
chris a lot of the team from the first
movie learned a lot um you know we made
that movie ourselves it was an
independent
uh canadian movie and um i think we
learned a lot we took what what we
learned and we made something that we're
super proud of and uh
it should be here in about
like ten months nine ten months
okay we'll wait we'll wait we can wait
for that um obviously you know people
love the movie people love seeing you
work with your cousin stephen amell it's
rare that you have two actors in the
same family that are super successful
and then even more rare when you
actually get to be in a movie together
is that cool was there ever any
hesitation about working with him
no it was
it was never hesitation but it was
always kind of like this would be super
fun but
we've never known like we've never known
each other on set so yeah to see how the
other person works and
and we found that we were very collab
very similar in certain ways and very
different in other ways but we we worked
very well together and you know the
funny thing is we're family and we're
close but
we've both been very busy and we
actually you know throughout covet had
not seen each other very much so it was
great to have him in town have his wife
and his daughter come to town my wife
and my son were here and we got to have
some you know some family hangouts
his mom
my family everyone is in town so it was
really nice to
actually have some family time well
getting to make a movie together it was
kind of the best of all worlds oh my god
and then it did so well
yeah so cool
think thank god
yeah wow so much to celebrate um so
speaking of your wife uh loki obsessed
with you two on social media um you're
so cute have you ever thought about
wanting to work with her in a future
project
um we've talked about working together
it's hard because i mean like
angelina jolie and brad pitt did it and
like that wasn't even a success and if
they can't do it like what the hell
chance do we have so
i think you know we we would love to
cameo in each other's stuff or or or
maybe do something a little
light-hearted but i think it would be
tough to play like
serious romantic opposites i think it
would be i don't know i don't know and
then you never say never the right
project comes along who knows but um
one of us has to watch the kids so it's
my turn next it's true oh i like that's
your turn um and just as we're wrapping
things up anything you can tease us
about hello stranger because you're in
this right and this is shooting in
canada with jordana brewster and sam
worthington
sam worthington see mooloo
i'm i'm going through the entire cast of
kim's convenience i'm i'm moving through
them i've gone back to back-to-back
movies um
so uh hello stranger is awesome it's
really cool um sci-fi
um romantic drama
thriller
um sam was amazing um i had a little bit
of overlap with him and then simu and i
have been working together
for uh for about a week now and jordana
and i mean the cast is fantastic uh
shooting in hamilton it's uh it's um ex
machina meets um blade runner meets um
black mirror so it's very cool
um i'm really excited you know i love
working on canadian projects and um
april uh our director
she's canadian she's fantastic she's
i'm very lucky i i
i'm just really lucky right now i think
work has been great yeah that's so cool
always so nice getting to talk to you i
definitely got the wrap i'm not even
sure how long ago so sorry i just
thought now um but you're always so cool
to talk to so congrats on everything
going on your life right now
thank you so much great talking with you
too yeah nice talking to you too okay
see ya